[Musique]
ça va ça vient
merci d'être avec tous les chefs et à
l'aube à basse altitude et soir si les
17h46 on est en direct de plus en plus
nombreux à nous regarder et merci à vous
moi ya plein de gens utilisant dire la
dj syrie a dirigé sans déconner ce que
j'ai fait est exceptionnel c'est
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous allez sur
les réseaux mais il ya une dar k c'est
qu'il ya des mecs qui ont pas fait de
sport depuis 18 sont deux et se prennent
tous pour des coachs de ses vrais gens
méchants rival et il ya tous les cas en
ce moment
maintenant le mec sans déconner ai dit
d'accord mon frère c'est prospère c'est
le roi du pain d épices mais il est
persuadé il est persuadé qu'il a
accordée ouf et qui peut donner des
conseils
1 voilà et être un scotch sportif à
l'eau mais qu'il arrive sans déconner il
a des jambes c'est des mikados ida non
mais c'est un truc de fou
les mecs ils ont des corps on dirait les
poteaux de koh lanta et ils sont
persuadés
l'un des coaches hausse porte le gars il
a toujours une grande bouteille d'eau à
la main qu'il n'a pas bu l'eau et à la
fin il vous dira au lieu de faire du
sport hydratez-vous le dj normalement il
ya toujours en boîte quand on va voir un
thon en boîte et il ya toujours le dj
jour le dj des danses et vas y toi
il veut par la personne qui regarde
personne il est dense et bail il est
tranquille y voit personne et tu as
toujours une meuf dans la moi c'est une
bombe atomique et tu vas voir un mec tu
lui dis moi c'est qu'il me fava est
normalement il ya la frappe directe
touche pas à ça c'est la pub de digi
spawn c'est à dire c'est la mode du dj
touche pas elle
ah ouais ouais ouais elle reste là tous
les soirs à la temps jusqu'à 5 heures du
matin après ils partent ensemble et je
peux vous dire qu'ils mix pack des
platines l'armée s'en est un vrai au
parc on sait déjà tous pris une banane 1
et vous le savez avec la meuf du dj en
boîte c'est officiel
[Musique]
je sais pas comment il fait historique
et c'est magique
il adore la lucarne mais là on en avril
j'ai fait deux premiers trimestres
catastrophique comme bien plus écoles
est-ce que je passe directement dans la
première que je veux pas dire si j'ai
envie de me faire une première s
tu vois je fais un actif tu auras voilà
si l'hymne de vente je m'appelle al wasl
et je plane première espérons par il
t'arrive non mais attendez je dois je
suis ok je peux dire voilà il te dis bah
voila j'ai envie de faire une première s
38 voilà j'ai envie de faire un kiff
voilà attendez c'est pas juste moi je
compte émettre le coup de collier au
troisième trimestre
deuxième et troisième trimestre en
rythme vous dire c'est mal tombé je
compte y mettre un dernier coup de
collier tout exploser la voilà les
deuxième et troisième semaines est donc
là forcément là ma mère va monter au
créneau à malam annou à dire vrai
comment ça fait mon fils il était très
chaud il n'a pas été travaillée tatati
et tatata ya plusieurs bras guerre en
boîte y aller il ya les dragueurs genre
un peu mystérieux kiki dont jamie tu
vois qui sont derrière une table comme
ça est un peu de leur mauvais ou pas toi
tu étais dragueur mystérieux doit juste
surtout celui qui a rien à faire quand
tu es beau tu attends juste que ça
vienne à web alors tu dois attendre
longtemps toi est-ce que tu connais lady
gaga rené malleville la la la la la la
la la
là où la la la la la
[Musique]
j'adore il ya toujours le mec mon frère
qui veut absolument qui veut absolument
béton c'est jusqu'à la fermeture est là
et il ya toujours un mec seul tour en
fin de soirée comme anne et le make mine
de rien tu sais quoi
il veut toujours le gras sont écoulés il
veut toujours aller autre part après ça
veut dire toutes les banques ont fermé
les yeux on fait quoi 00 17 heures du
matin ouais on fait quoi pas et qu'on
voulait rentrer les rabat joie
jean-louis je vais te dire quelque chose
renchérit tu parles comme tous les
parents et est un amour parce que tu
sais que je t'aime tu parles comme tous
les parents qui ont un fils qui est nul
à l'école un moment si celui là il est
tellement nulle
est-ce que c'est pas comme einstein
est-ce que c'est pas surdoué suis là et
après et là il t'amène faire des tests
confrères et y reviennent à la raison et
à ton père et à ton père cas-ci il fait
alors non non en fait il est nommé en
fait il est tombé grave et tombèrent pas
avec ça c'est pas un génie c'est sûr et
certain
non mais franchement je voulais vous
faire un petit kiff parce qu'on peut se
moquer d'elodie gossuin mais je sais pas
si vous le savez moi aussi une année
j'ai donné les points près de
l'orangerie 0 bonsoir belgrade
bonsoir maman bonne fête des mères c'est
la tête des verts ici en france dans
moins d'une demi heure dont bonne fête à
toutes les mamans
voici les premiers résultats du vote
français et je vous dis est la vérité
c'est la production et c'est donc moi
c'est moi qui pour qui je suis
producteur et benjamin tu pourra le dire
c'est pas la chaîne qui payent tous les
to les voilà qui donne les les
et voilà les la faim dans les boissons
se voulait donc on fait il faut le dire
c'est moi qui donne les douanes alors
voilà je le budget donc voila voila
c'est moi qui le fais moi qui donne les
dotations et la chaîne on comprend tout
à fait nous ont donné 1 rue nous c'est
nous qui donnons les dotations et c'est
nous qui avons donné jusqu'à 50000 euros
voilà je vous le dis parce qu'on veut
aider les hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de
france voilà aider les téléspectateurs
qui travaillent pas en ce moment
voilà lfr qui sait voilà faire un genre
de voilà de l'autre ils arrivent d'un
peu de bonheur
[Musique]